blinder passagier an bord in
niedersachsen genauer gesagt an einer
raststätte im landkreis oldenburg da
entdeckten zwei männer die einen
transporter gemietet haben plötzlich
eine schlange im ort oh mein gott
reptilien shop auf der fahrt von kiel
richtung bremen da stand in der meldung
glaube ich meter lange schlange und
haben uns dann einfach auf sich zukommen
lassen
mitten auf der autobahn a1 bemerkt die
fahrzeugbesatzung eine schlange im
fußraum des gemieteten transporters
nicht auszudenken wenn das während der
fahrt passiert wäre bilder wie wir sie
sonst nur häufig aus asien kennen
diesmal mitten in niedersachsen die
feuerwehr schnell vor ort doch die
bergung des blinden passagiers gestaltet
sich etwas schwierig
wir haben dann die motorhaube vorsichtig
aufgemacht und haben oder ich habe dann
festgestellt dass es sich vermutlich um
eine kornnatter handelt diese sind nicht
giftig ich kenne mich ein bisschen mit
reptilien aus und daher
haben wir dann versucht dem mit
feuerwehr handschuhen einzufangen was
ist ja letztendlich auch bewirkt ist als
sie dann im fluchtversuch nach unten
genommen hat die nato kommt nun erstmals
zu einem feuerwehrkameraden der
schlangen hält dann soll entschieden
werden was mit dem team passiert
[Musik]